hello everyone we are going to build
this recipe application in react so
before we dive into it let me just give
you a quick demo of how it's going to
work
essentially it grabs the recipes from an
external API so this is what happens
when the page first loads and then from
there on they can search for recipes so
if I type in shrimp it's gonna give me
the recipes that's involved shrimp and
then if I type in chicken it's gonna
give me the recipes that involve chicken
from there on we can view the recipe by
clicking this via recipe button and then
it takes close to that recipe using
react router once it's been loaded we
can go back to the home page by pressing
this go home button and it takes us back
to the home page again using react
router now you may notice that the
results that we looked for are still
there and this is because we are using
data persistence to store our data
locally for this project you are
expected to have a little bit of
knowledge of JavaScript react and react
router okay so without any further ado
let's get started
alright so to get started I've already
created a project folder for you using
the create x ab CLI so inside of this
folder I've included that CSS that I've
written for this project which lives
right there so feel free to take a look
at it and I've also installed the
packages that we're going to need for
this project so I've installed bootstrap
and I've also installs this react
Rotterdam package and these three they
already come built into a create react
our project
okay so I've I will link this project in
the video description so go and download
it and once you have downloaded it just
go ahead and navigate to it in your
terminal type in NPM install to install
the all the packages and the non modules
folder and once you've done that just
type in NPM start or yawn start to
launch this project into your web
browser okay so come on
this is what we are going to stop in
it's just a blank screen with basically
a header and a title that reads recipe
search and this is what's coming on in
this appliques file okay so as you know
we are going to type in the values well
the names of the recipes to search for
them so how do we actually search for
recipes well we need the input form so
to do that let's just first create a new
folder in this source folder and I'm
gonna name it components within this
components folder let's just create a
new file and call it form yes
all right in there first things first we
need to import reactor and react and
then I'm gonna create a stateless
functional components and I'm gonna call
it form and it's going to be a stateless
functional component because we don't
need any state in this component so if a
component is needed in state that means
we can make it a stateless functional
component and not a class-based
component all right so I'm just going to
implicitly return some GSX
inside of it I'm gonna create a form
come on and we don't need the action so
inside of this form let's just create a
new input the type of text let's get rid
of this ID and the name for now and I'm
also gonna create a button that says
search and before I forget let's just go
ahead and export this right here at the
bottom so export default form
excellent now let's go back to ab GS and
input this so input form from and then
we need to stay in the same directory go
into the components directory and then
import form all right so let's just
render it out right there just below the
header so there we go let's go back to
the web browser and make sure that it's
showing up yes it is so let's just
create a
method inside of this component and hook
it up to this formula jazz because we
need to first make sure that everything
is working correctly so I'm gonna call
this method get recipe and this method
is going to be responsible for making
the API call okay and let's set it to a
error function now this syntax may look
a bit weird to you you may be used to
seeing something like a constructor
function and then inside of it
you basically type in your methods like
this and then you have to hook them up
in your constructor function like this
dog cat recipe equals this dot get
recipe don't bind and then you bind in
your methods whatever but this has been
removed or you can say that deprecated
in react 16 so essentially in react 16
you don't really need a constructor
function you can even declare your state
without a constructor function just like
that okay so this is just a neat bit of
syntax in the new version of react and I
think this is much better and much more
practical than their previous versions
anyway getting back to the topic first
of all let's just console dot box I'm
thinking to this method just to make
sure that it's working fine so I'm just
gonna consider flog saying
working but how do we hook it up to this
form component well we first need to go
ahead and pass this data to the some
component and how do you pass data to
another components you use props so I'm
gonna name this prop the same as this
method so I'm gonna say get recipe
equals this so this refers to this up
component and then this don't get recipe
ok press save now back in form yes we do
have access to this get recipe prop
because we set it up right there
but to access it we can't really use the
this props approach because this keyword
only works in class-based components but
this is a stateless functional component
which means we have to pass
an argument right there called props now
with this props refers to these right
there so whatever get passed in there
get stored into this argument so this
props is basically an object so to
access the properties of an object you
type in well props dot and then whatever
the name of the property is now in our
case we are going to set up an attribute
called spawn submit which is a built-in
react react attribute and then we can
say props dot and then the name of the
prop is get recipe so let's just copy it
and place it right there
excellent press save Abdo GS and now
what we want well we want this console
dot log to show up as soon as we press
this button so now if I open up my JoePa
tools go to the console press search ooh
what's happening there well keep your
keep your eye right about there as soon
as I press the search button
keep your eye there did you see that
that working console log appeared for
like just a split second but then it
disappears and this is because we are
going through a full page refresh this
this full page refresh is the default
behavior of any web page and to change
that all we need to do is we need to
pass in an argument he actually let me
just convert that to a hello function
first so I don't have to bind it so this
e is basically the event object in
JavaScript this is nothing specific to
react so since this is an object means
we can access the properties of this
object so I can say e dot prevent
default and this method is going to
prevent the default behavior of this
webpage which is what that is going to
refresh so now if I press save go back
to the web browser press search we can
see that the working console log is
showing up brilliant okay
well what do we need to do next
well we need to first let's just let's
just make sure that we are actually
reading the values that we type in there
so first of all we need to set up a name
attribute because this is what we're
going to use to read the values from the
input okay so name and I'm gonna name it
recipe or let's just call it recipe name
okay
I'm gonna copy this and within this get
recipe method I'm gonna create a new
constant and I'm gonna call it same as
that recipe name equals so again this
event object means we can read the
properties from it so e dot target dot
elements and then what do we need to
access what we need to access this name
attribute so what's the name of this
name attribute its recipe name so either
target or element start named the recipe
name and then what do we need to access
from it we need to access its value so
talk about here okay now instead of
console logging this working string
let's just actually console dot log this
recipe name constant that we just
created
right so let's go back to the web
browser and type in anything typing
chicken press search and there we go
this is working just fine okay now let's
get into some more interesting stuff we
need to make an API call to a website
and then we are reading the data from
the website and showing up to our web
application and what's the website that
we need to make the API calls ooh well
it's this recipe API calls for food to
folk that's that's kind of a weird name
but food to 4.com slash about slash API
now you can read this but for the most
part all you need to do is you first
need to sign up for the website it's
completely free and you need to obtain
an API key because you need that in
order to work with their data
essentially an API key is a way for
websites to know who you are
and what kind of baits are you trying to
access so the the use your API key that
are associated to your email address and
then they just basically want to know
what kind of date are you trying to
access that's the whole purpose of
obtaining the API keys okay so all you
need to do is just press the sign up
button and then it will redirect you
back to this page once you have got your
API key so the URL that we need to make
the API call two lives right there now
see this is the URL that we need and see
this key parameter right there this is
where your API key should go so once you
have done that your URL should look
something like this right there see this
is the exact same API right there sorry
this is the exact same URL apart from
the fact that this API key variable has
been replaced by my actual API key so
all I did was I first signed up then I
copied this URL
I pasted it right there and then instead
of this API key wrapped within those
curly braces I just pasted my API key
right there and what I've been looking
for by default we are looking for this
shredded chicken and these are the
results that we are getting back and you
may also notice that there's also this
count parameter right there and we can
change that we will do that later on in
the video but we can change that to
anything we can change that to five 10
15 whatever you like it just depends on
how many results you want to show so in
this case the count is set to five which
means we are getting an array of recipes
and this array has five different
objects and then you see that these are
the properties that we're going to read
in order to access the data so this
publisher title recipe ID just some of
these we're gonna use in our web
application okay so let's actually go
ahead and copy this URL okay go back to
our application and I'm actually going
to just go ahead and create a new
constant but all I'm gonna do there is
I'm first going to
extract my API key because I'm gonna
steal that in a new constant so there we
go because it's always a good practice
to just store your important data into
your own constants in case you need it
later on okay and I'm just gonna go
ahead and create a new string and paste
my API key right there okay so once
that's been done we are now ready to
make the HTTP call to this URL right
there so to do that I'm first going to
go ahead and cut this link out just like
that and inside this get recipe method
just below this prevent default call I'm
gonna create a new constant and I'm
gonna call a API and let's call call and
for now I'm just going to go ahead and
initialize a shrink and inside of that
I'm going to paste this link right there
I didn't seem right let's just fix that
there we go okay so we're gonna make use
of something called async await and the
fetch API to make the call to this link
right there so how do you initialize a
async await function or in this case how
do we make this method asynchronous well
just before we declare the method we're
gonna type the keywords async
okay and then right there we're making
the API call we type in the keyword of
eight and to actually make the HTTP call
we're gonna use the fetch API so to do
that I'm again going to go ahead and cut
this link out and I'm gonna type in the
keyword fetch and within there instead
of initializing the string I'm gonna use
the es6
template literals so to do that it's
just using the backticks and then i'm
going to paste the link right there so
we need to change a couple of things now
because remember we have our API key
stored in this constant right there so
in es6 template literals we are allowed
to inject the variables inside our
string
so to do that we're going to go ahead
and copy this API key constant and we're
going to inject it right there where the
key is required so to insert a template
that roll all you do is you type in the
dollar sign and then a couple of kali
braces and then whatever goes inside of
these curly braces and basically what we
want to do so in this case we just want
to inject this API key variable so again
I'm just gonna go ahead and copy this
and paste it right there
and what do we need to do next well the
default search for now is just shredded
chicken right there later on we will
change that to the whatever we type into
our form but for now let's just leave it
to shredded chicken okay so I'm actually
gonna get rid of this console log right
there because we don't need that anymore
so this is just making the API call it's
it's not actually grabbing any kind of
data so to do that I'm actually gonna
create a new constant and I'm gonna call
it results or let's just call it data
and we're gonna set it to the return
value of this fetch function right there
so again to grab the value we're gonna
first type the keyword of eight okay and
then we also need to convert this
whatever we get back from this API to a
JSON format so you may be used to sing
something like you know JSON the parse
or json stringify but what's how clean
this is in fact a API all you need to do
is you need to type in the contents name
which in our case is API call and then
we just call the JSON method there we go
just like so okay so now whatever we get
back from the API is going to be stored
in this data constant right there so
let's just check what's inside of this
data constant so if I console.log this
data object not remember this method is
going to fire as soon as we press this
button right there
so now let's just go back to our
application and press search
what's that no access control allow
origin some web sites do not allow local
servers to access their data now in our
case we are using our localhost 3000 to
access the data from this food to fork
website so we need to do something to
trick this food to four servers into
thinking that they are a legitimate
website so in other in other words we
are live on the servers so how do you
fix that
well there's a very handy tool for that
it's called course any bear Hiroko com
so all we need to do is we need to go
ahead and copy this URL okay and go back
to our application and just before our
link begins
we just prefix it with this URL that we
discovered right there all this is going
to do is it's going to trick this
website into thinking that our server
which in our case is localhost this is
actually a live server that live
somewhere on the Internet okay that's
all this URL is going to do so now if I
press save and then go back to our
application press search and hopefully
this should give us some sorts of data
and yes it does
so this essentially is an object and the
value of that is this data constant
right there so if I expand it this is
the count so remember we are getting
array of five objects because we have
set the count to five so if I change the
count to let's say ten let's see what we
get back so press search and there we go
we get an array of ten objects so let's
just go ahead and crack open this
receipe array and let's take a look at
what's inside of this well it's
basically like I said it's an array and
inside of that is just a count of object
so that count is what we type in right
there so let's just crack open the first
one
so these are just a bunch of properties
that we are going to use in order to
display the data on a
so what do we need here well actually
access this data what we need to do is
we need to drill down into this row
first this recipe is array so we're
gonna have to say something like beta so
remember data is this whole object so to
drill down into recipes we have to say
data recipes and now if I console.log
this we get back the array that we need
so this is the array and let's just say
that we want to go to this first element
in this array so I can say it says again
to access a number in an array you use
the index in this case it's 0
so we want to access the first element
and inside of this and inside of that
let's just try an access this recipe IDs
let's just copy that and paste it right
there and let's see what we got back so
press s and there we go we get the
recipe ID back but this isn't what we
want we actually want to display the
data on our actual webpage which is this
whole thing right there so how do we do
that well let's take a look so to
actually display this piece of data we
don't really have anywhere to store that
inside of so we do have this constant
called data but this only exists inside
of this method so now would be a good
time to introduce state within our
application so to do that let's just
gonna type in the keyword state and I'm
just gonna set it to an empty object now
again you might be used to doing
something like typing in a constructor
and then declaring your state like that
but like I said in react 16 and further
on you don't need the constructor
function at all so you can just delete
that altogether and what you can do is
you can just simply declare your state
like that
so what kind of state do you want to
trace what we want to do is we want to
set up an array which is going to store
whatever we get back from the API and
what do we get back we get back an array
so to do that let's just create a first
piece of State called recipes and set it
to an empty array excellent now how do
we actually make use of this steak right
there well instead of constant logging
this piece of data right there let's
just do something else let's just use
the built in set state method to set
this piece of data to this recipes array
so to do that I'm just gonna say this
just set state and it's gonna take an
object and within there we want to grab
the recipe state and we want to set it
to data just like that okay so now
instead of console logging what we get
back from this data less console.log
this piece of steak right there
so console o´clock and this state that
recipes okay let's go back to the web
browser open up our console press search
and we should get back our piece of
state and that we do and inside of this
piece of state we have an object and
then inside of the object is this
recipes array right there so all we want
to do right there is we only want this
array right there so to do that let's
just say data dot and then is this
recipes array right there because we
want to set this recipes array to this
recipes array right there okay so data
recipes there we go
go back to the web browser press search
and now all we get back is an array and
within that array there's just a bunch
of objects so this is all well and good
but how do we actually display this data
onto our actual screen
so to do that let's just do something
more interesting for now all I'm gonna
do is I'm going to open up a JavaScript
expression right there which means and
by the way in gsx opening up a pair of
curly braces means that you want to
inject something that is related to
JavaScript okay so to do that I'm gonna
make use of an array methods called map
now map is a new method that was
introduced in a later version of
JavaScript and essentially it allows you
to go through each element inside of an
array and then you can manipulate it you
can change it anything you want to do
with it so it's kind of like the for
each method but in JSX we can't really
use the for loop or the for each loop so
we're gonna have to make do with what we
have so what we have here is the array
method array dot map method so in this
case the recipe state is an array so all
we can do is we can say this dot state
put up recipes and then we call in the
method called map and this method takes
a callback function so let's just give
it a callback function and we also give
it a argument right there and argument I
should say or a parameter and this
parameter is going to contain each of
the elements that are inside of this
recipes array once the state has been
set so let's just call it a individual
recipes just like that and then within
there let's just return a paragraph that
says and again since we're gonna make
use of this javascript thing inside of
this GSX paragraph tags we have to
introduce curly braces so what do we
want to access well for now let's just
say recipe and then let's just crack
open one of these and recipe title for
now let's just console let's just print
out recipe door title so remember it's
gonna print out ten different titles on
the screen because it's going to loop
through
each of these elements right there and
the number of them is ten so we're gonna
get ten titles printing out to the
screen
okay so again press Save go back to the
web browser there are no errors which is
good so now if I press search I should
get some titles onto the screen yes we
did this is brilliant but we also have
an error it reads each child in an array
or iterator should have a unique key
prop and this error is something to do
with reacts essentially it's asking us
to set a parameter called key to each of
these elements that have been looped
over and the reason for this is that yet
wants to know what each of these
elements are I mean there is no way for
react to know what this title is what
this title is all this doing is it's
reading the properties of each of the
objects right there but it also needs to
know that in in future in case we need
to manipulate any of these so react can
just grab the key prop and then from
there it can do his thing so to do that
all I'm going to do is I'm going to set
this recipe ID which is this right there
I can also set the title or the source
URL as long as is something unique and
different to compare to the other
objects it will do but just for the sake
of simplicity I'm gonna copy this and
I'm gonna say that key equals and again
I'm gonna have to open up a JavaScript
expression and inside of this I'm gonna
say recipe dart recipe underscore ID now
if I press save and go back to the web
browser press search we can see that all
the titles are printing out to the
screen and we also don't have any errors
this is just a es lint complaining that
recipe name has been declared but it's
not been used and this isn't really
something to worry about so let's just
move on
currently we are just getting the
default value which is this shredded
chicken right there
but what we want to do is we want to get
the results of whatever the user types
into this input form right there
so to change that we already have a
value from that form which we grabbed
earlier on using the event object so all
we can do is we can use this recipe name
constant and like I said this is a
template shrink so we can actually
inject this variable right there instead
of this shredded chicken so I can do
this I can just cut this out okay and
then to open up a template Latrobe it
type in the dollar sign followed by a
pair of curly braces and then within
there we can inject this variable right
there just like that okay press save go
back to the web browser and now if we
type in let's say shrimp press search
and we are indeed getting the results
that involves shrimp on the screen as
well as in the console right there okay
so what's next
so let's actually grab a bit more than
just the titles so if I just crack open
one of these objects right there we can
use a bunch of properties there's what
we're going to use is we're gonna use
this title which we already use and
we're also gonna use this publisher name
and we're also gonna use this image URL
but for now let's just throw in this
image and see how it goes so I'm just
gonna go ahead and copy this I'm gonna
go back to our application and instead
of just returning this one single
paragraph let's actually just cut it out
open up a pair of parentheses and inside
of it let's create a div throw in that
paragraph tag and let's also add in a
image tag just above this paragraph Saxo
and the source is gonna be actually this
recipe dot and then the image URL
as always to open up a JavaScript
expression you have to throw in a pair
of curly braces and then recipe and then
image URL so what kind of description do
we need to give it to this image tag
well we can just throw in the title
there just like we did right there so we
can say again to initialize a JavaScript
expression come on we have to first open
up a pair of curly braces and then
recipe dot title excellent now if we go
back to the web browser and press search
let's look for pizza this time and we
should get back the images they look
hideous at the moment but we will fix
that so why is this giving an error
again this key prop error even though we
have already passed the key right there
well the error here is that the key has
to be passed within the most parent
element so what's the most parent
element in this case well it's this div
right there so I'm just going to put
this out and paste it right there just
like that
so now if you go back to our application
press pizza and yeah it's working out
fine but it's looking rather hideous at
the moment so we gonna fix that next so
to do that we're gonna make use of
bootstrap which I already have included
in our package JSON and as well as our
index Taji as well right there so to
make use of bootstrap we're just gonna
add a bunch of classes from the
bootstrap framework but before we do
that let's take care of this piece of
code right there all we are doing there
is we are mapping over this piece of
state right there but this is a bit
messy I mean we don't want to do that in
our app components so to take care of
that let's just transfer this into its
own
opponents what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
create a new components in the
components folder and I'm gonna call it
recipes OGS okay once I'm in there
what's gonna import react from react
after that let's just create a stateless
functional component because again we
don't need any state in there so we can
make this a stateless functional
component so to do that I'm just gonna
call it recipes and I'm gonna set it
equal to another function and I'm going
to implicitly return some GSX
so first of all I'm just gonna return it
div and within this day for now let's
just type in recipes just to make sure
that it's working and right there let's
just export defaults at the bottom
excellent now let's go back to see our
app.js file and just underneath this
form component let's import the recipes
so import recipes from and then it's the
components directory and then recipes
okay so I'm actually going to cut this
out and I'm just going to go ahead and
render out their recipes components
press save go back to the web browser
and we do have our recipes component
showing up okay but we don't want it to
just render out this text we wanted to
actually display the data that we were
previously getting so how do we do that
well first of all we need to pass this
state this recipes array to this recipes
component and then in the inside of this
recipes component that is where we are
going to map over that piece of state
right there so how do we pass this piece
of state to our recipes components well
as always to pass anything inside a
react you have to use props so to do
that I'm just gonna pass the new props
and I'm gonna call it recipes okay and
and I'm gonna set it to this dot state
dot recipes excellent so now this prop
means that we do have access
to our recipe state that lives there so
now back in recipes as well to get
access to this prop right there we first
need to pass in an argument right there
called
props because this is the only way we
can access the props we can't really say
something like this dot Probst or
whatever because that this keyword will
not work inside of this jet LAG's
that lives inside of this error function
okay if it was a class-based component
then we could have used it but in
stateless functional components there's
no way we can access the props using of
this keyword okay
so now how do we proceed with our
recipes props well it's the same as what
we did right there so I'm actually just
going to paste the piece of code that I
copied that I cut earlier and all I'm
gonna do within there is I'm going to
get rid of this keyword and I'm also
gonna get rid of this state because the
state does not exist in this component
instead I'm gonna type in crops and
what's the name of the prop is this
recipe so props dot recipes and then
it's the exact same thing that we have
been following so again let's just break
it down we pass the props property they
pass the props argument that props
argument has access to this recipes prop
right there and then inside of this
inside of this tip what we are doing is
we are mapping over this piece of state
right there
and this gets filled once this search
recipe button gets calls okay and then
once that's been calls that means that
this this prop has access to this piece
of [ __ ] right there which means we can
actually map over inside of another
component and that component right now
is this recipes components okay
a lot of talking now let's save the file
go back to the web browser and see if
that works
let's just open up the console and let's
look for chicken press search and we are
indeed getting back ten different values
sorry 10 different recipe
for the chicken and this is brilliant so
now that we have taken care of this
recipes component let's go ahead and
actually style our application because
it it looks very ugly right now so let's
continue with that so when I say styling
I mean that I'm just gonna add a bunch
of CSS properties that I've already
declared inside of this app dot CSS file
so if something doesn't make sense to
you then I've named this classes very
appropriately so just have a look at
this file and it should make everything
clear to you and like I said before I've
already installed bootstrap into this
project as well and this is being
imported right there inside of this
index or JS file and we're gonna make
use of bootstrap as well okay so we're
not really gonna make any changes to
this applet J's file instead let's just
first open up this form to J's file and
this is where we're gonna get started
with our styling okay so the first thing
that I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna add
a style attribute right there and this
takes a JavaScript expression and then
inside of it you can declare declare an
object and then there you can define
your Styles so the first thing that I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna declare a margin
bottom okay and I'm gonna set it to two
Ram okay now next step I'm gonna do is
press save and I'm gonna give this input
a class name of form underscore
underscore input copy that and I'm gonna
give this button a class name of form
underscore underscore button brilliant
let's just go back to our application
now and we can see that those Styles are
being applied okay now for the main
styling we're gonna stay in this recipe
as well
so right now it's very simple what we're
gonna completely transform this
structure right there so what I'm gonna
do is I'm actually going to go ahead and
put this whole thing out just like that
so start with a div okay so this div is
gonna act as a bootstrap container okay
and inside of this day let's just throw
in a row okay
now next up what do we need to do well
this is where we're going to throw in
our map function okay so to do that
let's just let me just take a look at
what I'm doing here because this
tutorial is not scripted so I just
really need to be careful with the
classes so I don't mess anything up
anyway so I need to add the bootstrap
columns so what would be the best place
to do that well this is one individual
if that's being rendered out to the web
browser so that means this would be an
ideal place to throw in the bootstrap
column class okay so to do that I'm
actually going to cut this whole thing
out just like that create a new class
and I'm gonna cool it Cole - MD - for
excellent so now let's just go ahead and
open up this div and inside of this div
let's also throw in and other class name
and call it recipe underscore underscore
box brilliant okay let's carry on and
what do we need to do next well seeing
as we are mapping over we are throwing
initiative inside of this map function
that means we get we have access to
every property that this recipe has so
the first thing that we're gonna do is
we gonna throw in an image tag and the
source is gonna be again recipe dot I
believe it was image underscore URL and
the old was recipe underscore the recipe
I believe it was titled yes it was okay
what's next
well let's also give this image a class
I'm gonna say class name and I'm gonna
set it equal to recipe underscore
underscore box and then it's IMG let's
just break these attributes down to
their own lines just so it's a bit more
clear
okay let's indent that in let's get rid
of that there okay so what's next well
after the image tag let's just go ahead
and underneath this image tag that's
open up a div and cool it recipe
underscore underscore text okay inside
of there what are we doing well let's
open up a JavaScript expression because
this is really going to throw out our
recipe title so let's just say recipe
doctor title okay and let's wrap this
inside of a cage v tag okay just so it
looks the serve it actually looks like a
title so recipe come on on this recipe
doc title okay let's just take a look at
how it's looking like so far well it
says or we see it's not defined so line
number 12 and yep
of course it's not defined so press save
and go back to the web browser let's
just close that for now and let's pizza
search and see what we get back oh we
are getting stuff back but it's not
looking very promising at the moment so
let's just go ahead and fix this so the
source for this tag is of course is the
image URL so I typed in IMG anyway let's
take a look at it now so pizza search
this is looking much better now okay
well what's next
well let's also grab another property
from this array called publisher okay
this one right there
and again it's complaining about that
key prop and we will pass that in a
moment
in fact let's do
right now so what's the most parent div
is dis component why they're so sorry
this tip right there so let's just say
the key equals recipe dot title and that
should fix it and while I'm here let's
also give this each of the columns a bit
of spacing towards the bottom so I'm
gonna say style equals and then an
object that says margin bottom is let's
just give it to RAM okay press a so what
is next
well do we were gonna throw in the
publisher so to do that let's just
shall we throw in a paragraph tag right
there yeah staying inside of this div
let's just throw in a paragraph tag and
give it a class of recipes underscore
underscore title and let's also copy
this class and paste it right there and
this should be title and this should be
subtitle okay so let's hope let's just
type in publisher so this shows up and
then let's throw that in a span tag so
span and then inside of this pan what do
we need to do well let's just open up a
JavaScript expression and type in recipe
publisher okay so what is next so we're
also gonna add a button which we can
click and then we get taken to the
recipe and we will hook that up using
react router later on but for now let's
just go ahead and add it so below this
just come on this recipe on this court
text if let's just open up a a button
tag okay and cool it for now let's just
call it new recipe and give it a class
of recipe underscore underscore button
brilliant now let's go back to our
application and this should look the way
we want it to look okay it's
looking promising for the most part I
still kind of don't like the way it's
looking so I probably miss type
something so I think the class name is
recipe buttons actually it is and this
should be recipe text and it should be
recipe this should be recipes box okay
my mistake okay let's go back to our
application again press search okay this
is looking good but again it's not
perfect and I'm pretty sure that I'm
typing out the class names somewhere
wrong so it's recipe underscore
underscore buttons actually a thing I
just typed one underscore right there so
now if I press search there we go
this is looking much better now so see I
don't like how some of these boxes are
longer in height and some are small in
height so let's just type in something
else chicken see notice that you know
when the name gets longer the box itself
gets longer as well
so how did it fix that well let's just
make use of something inside of
something very handy inside of
JavaScript so to do that we're gonna do
this inside of this recipe title so
we're gonna make use of a JavaScript
method called
substring so it's better to explain it
while we do it so let's just open up
let's just expand this h5 tag right
there let's put that in a separate line
and right there what we're gonna do is
we're gonna say if recipes dot title
okay so dot length so remember this is a
string and strings in Java scripts have
a property called length so we can check
that if recipe or title document is
small
than 20 okay so we're using the turn
area pricing right there so it kind of
looks like if-else statement but we
can't really use if-else statements
inside of JSX so we're gonna have to
make do with the ternary operator okay
so if recipe title top length is smaller
than 20 then this question mark refers
the then calls inside of the if-else
statement then what we want to do is we
want to open up a template string and
inside of it we're just gonna render it
out a recipe oops that's not how it
should be it should be like that we're
gonna render out just the recipe door
title as it is so if the the length of
the title is less than 20 characters
then we are just going to render out the
recipe title just as it is okay else
so this colon stands for else so if this
condition isn't true then this is what's
going to happen so else let's open up a
template string again else recipe dot
title dot and this is where we're gonna
make use of the substring method inside
of JavaScript okay so this essentially
takes a couple of arguments the first
one is where it's going to start and the
second one is where we want our string
to trim so if the length of the title is
smaller than 20 characters that means it
can fix inside of just one box if it's
greater than 20 characters which this
one is what we can do is we can cut it
down to just 25 characters so to do that
we need to start with the first index
stuff so the first letter which is right
there and the index of that is 0 so 0
and then we just want to trim it down to
25 characters so this is what the second
argument is going to be okay so once
it's been done once the character has
been trimmed let's also give the user
some kind of feedback that this string
is longer than it's appearing got to be
so to do that let's type in three dots
right there
okay go back to the web browser again
search for chicken breasts search and
now we can see that the titles that are
longer than 20 characters have this kind
of a nice you know three ellipsis
showing up right there and those titles
that are smaller than 20 characters they
are just showing in their full length
and this is exactly what we wanted to do
okay so let's continue okay so now we're
gonna add react router to our
application more specifically we're
gonna make this view recipe button work
okay so to do that we're obviously gonna
need react router and I did tell you
earlier that I already have installs the
react router package so which lives
right there okay so what we're gonna do
for that is we're gonna create a new
component inside of this components
folder and we're gonna call it router
yes and this component is ultimately
going to replace this app component
which lives which currently lives inside
of this index or JS file and this is
what we're going to render out to the
web browser okay so what do we actually
need inside of this router components
well obviously we need react so import
react from react and we're also gonna
grab a bunch of named exports from this
react return package so we're gonna grab
in fact let's just first say imports and
then react router Dom and then we can
type in the properties so we need
browser router we need switch and we
also need what we need route okay if you
are new to react router then I highly
recommend you first learn about react
router and I do have a video for that on
my channel so go check that out it will
give you a basic idea of react router
and how it works okay so now you may
notice that this new update in Ria's
code it basically doesn't give you any
hard
unless you use the variables that you
are using in your application so let's
say that this react it's it's not
highlighted it's usually in colors and
the reason is appearing this dim is
because we haven't used it yet so this
is a nice way of vs code of the you know
tell you that this is the stuff that you
haven't used yet so use it okay so now
if I just create a new component and I'm
gonna call it router and I'm gonna set
it to a stateless functional component
and let's just make it written some Jes
X so now as soon as I create this div
you can see that this line gets
highlighted and this is because react
has and this is because BS code has told
us that you know this this thing right
there has been used but we haven't used
any of these properties yet so this is
why they are still appearing grey okay
coming back to the topic so we don't
actually need this div what we're gonna
do is we're gonna wrap everything inside
of this browser router so I'm gonna
place it right there and inside of it
what do we need well we need our route
so to throw in our out we just type in
route and it's a self closing tag and
inside of it we add a component
attribute and we also add a I leave is
path yeah but I think that comes before
the component so path equals and
anything that that goes inside of it
okay so how are we going to structure
this well for the home component which
obviously gets represented by this
forward slash so if the path is this
forward slash then we are going to show
up our app dot J's components so applet
J s is obviously this whole thing right
there so to do that we first need to
import our app components or imports app
from and then we need to jump up by
directory and then this app so if the
compose if the path is this forward
slash and show us this app components
and we also going to add a new route and
that route is going to be that
individual recipe whatever we click on
so we don't really have any component
for that yet but for the time being
let's just create a new component and
call it recipe now pay attention this is
recipe and this is just an individual
recipe okay it's very easy to make
mistakes so just pay attention right
there create a new components import
react from react and then this create a
stateless function component for now
anyway and let's call it recipe and set
it to another function and let's just
implicitly return some JSX okay dev and
let's just type in recipe component and
export this right here at the bottom so
export defaults recipe excellent now we
need to actually input this into our
router because this is what we're gonna
use in order to render it out so import
recipe from and then it's in the same
directory recipe right there okay I'm
just going to duplicate this line and
I'm gonna say that if so what what path
do we need well it's going to be
complicated than what we are used to but
for now let's just throw in the path
recipe so if the path is forward slash
forward slash recipe then render out
this recipe components okay well
currently it's not going to work because
this router file only exists in our
components folder and we actually need
to make use of it so to make use of it
let's just go back to our indexes as
well and let's completely trash this app
component right there and instead let's
import I believe it's router from and
then I think it's in the components
folder and then router ok so now instead
of this up component we're gonna make
use of this roxtor component right there
ok save you go back to the web browser
and it says expert default imported as
router was not found and I know what the
mistake is
back in watts yes we need to make use of
this switch statement right there so to
do that let's just type switch and then
throw in our routes and I also forgot to
export this so expert defaults and then
router so now if I go back to the web
browser we can see that we have our app
component in all its glory and we can
still search for recipes so if I type in
chicken I can get the results that
involve chicken and then right there
what come what other path did we create
we created this recipe path so if I type
in /r s opee I don't get recipe and this
is because react router can be a huge
stick at time so to fix that all we need
to do is we need to give in the keyword
exact right there to the topmost
component what this is going to do is
it's going to make sure that only render
out this app components when this path
is exactly this forward slash and
there's there is nothing else in front
of it so now if you press save go back
to the web browser we can see that we
are indeed on this recipe path and we
are getting this recipe component render
out to our application okay so now let's
actually make the button work so what I
mean is you don't this person right
there let's actually make this work so
when we press it we actually get taken
to the recipe okay so to do that it's
going to be a bit more complicated than
what we are used to but let's give it a
go so back in this route to dodge as
well we don't really want this static
recipe path what we want is we want a
path parameter or in other words is also
called a route parameter so to start
Iraq parameter you type in colon and
then anything that goes after it is
considered as
a parameter or a variable so what do we
need in this case well you can name it
anything but we're gonna grab the recipe
ID to access the data of the recipe so
for the sake of simplicity and relevance
let's just type in ID okay now this path
will only work so if I just simply go to
recipe it's not gonna work so forward
slash recipe you can see that it's not
gonna work and this is because it also
that it's also gonna take a route
parameter so if I type anything after
that let's see if I type in one then we
can see that the recipe component is
indeed showing up okay so this is how
it's going to work so what's next well
you know this button this view recipe
button this lives inside of this recipe
so J's file which is this thing right
there so to make to make this work we're
gonna grab and in the named export from
the react watch dump packets and let's
just type it in first come on
and this package is cold well this is a
named export in needs and this is called
linked now this link essentially works
the same as the anchor tag in HTML all
it does is it directs you to whatever
link it is you know pointing at so to do
that let's just first go ahead and split
this button into multiple lines and what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna cook this this
view recipe text and then I'm just going
to go ahead and throw in this view
recipe and convert this to a link it's
not gonna do anything just yet well
let's just go ahead and press save go
back to the web browser search for the
recipes and our application breaks this
is because we need to specify a to
attribute to this this link right there
so essentially it's the same as saying
so you know two is basically telling it
what path doesn't need to go to so in
our application we have two power
so what we're doing here is we need we
need to tell this link to which of these
two paths to go to once it's been
clicked so now obviously we need to go
to this recipe /id
and now remember this is a prima test of
anything that goes in there get soup
gets replaced by this ID parameter okay
so we're actually gonna make use of
template strings right there because we
need to inject some variables so to do
that how do we do that because the
template strings don't really seem to be
working well to fix this all we need to
do is we need to open up a JavaScript
expression and then inside of it we need
to open up a object and then we type in
path name now this is where we're going
to assign the path so if the path is and
and let's set it to template literals
because remember inside of a JavaScript
expression inside of a JavaScript
expression we can use the template rules
so if the path is forward slash recipe
now again this is ID so that means we
need to grab the ID of the recipe so
remember we are in fact mapping over the
the whole recipes array right there so
to grab the recipes all we need to do is
forward slash recipes and then remember
we can't inject the variables so you
throw in the recipe ID we can just say
that recipe so remember this recipe is
referring to this recipe argument right
there
so recipe dot and then the properties
that we need is called come on it's not
their recipe underscore ID okay and now
how do we actually proceed with that I
mean yes we do have this path provided
so if I go back to the web browser press
search and you can see that this has
indeed been converted to a link so now
if I hover over it I get this you know
hand sign and then it's showing me that
it's actually a link so let's see what
happens when we press this button new
recipe boom
we do indeed get taken so remember this
is the recipe this is the recipe Rd and
once we hit it we get taken to this
recipe route right there so now if we
choose a different recipe let's say we
click on that we can see that the recipe
ID has been changed because the recipe
ID is just a number and that is what
we're using to throw in to our URL does
that make sense well I hope it does okay
so what's next well how do we actually
access the data inside of this recipe
J's file first of all we need to convert
this to a class-based component because
we're gonna use some of the properties
that are only available inside of the
class-based component so to do that
class recipe extends react dot component
excellent
let's just open up a pair of curly
braces type and render and return some
JSX so for now let's just return again
their recipe component okay
press search go back to the web browser
make sure everything is working fine
yesterday
okay so if we didn't know any better we
would know that what's going on inside
of this recipe component but we do
indeed have access to props right so if
I type in console dot log and then just
props so we all we're doing here is
we're just console logging the props so
as soon as this component is loaded it
says prop just not defined began this is
because we need to lock historic crops
ok go back to the web browser open up
the console so there we go and we do
indeed have an object so if I expand it
this is just a lot of react rotted stuff
that's been bound to this recipe
component because we specified it right
there in this recipe storage as well so
the reason we are getting
all this react grata stuff is because we
created a link right there and then this
link belongs to react router so that
means it's been bound to this recipe
component as well okay so now if we go
ahead and take a look at it we can see
that we have a location objects and if I
expand it this is the path name that we
set right there in recipes JS file this
thing right there okay and we also have
another property called state and this
is what we're gonna use in order to
display the actual recipe onto this
recipe component so to do that what are
we gonna do well back in this recipes
dot J's file we are going to create an
other attribute inside of this object
right there so right after this string
ends actually let me just break it down
to a new line so path name and then I
believe it's that one right there and
this one is gonna be called state ok now
this state is gonna contain a another
object and the name of the object is
gonna be recipe ok and let's just pull
it now like I said we're gonna use the
recipe title in order to display the
data so just to do that let's just say
recipe dots and then title and we do
have access to this recipe because we
are mapping over a recipe array and then
we are setting up this recipe argument
right there
press save go back to the web browser
and again expand this object and if i
refresh it we can see that the state is
still undefined and this is because the
state is only going to get calls when we
press this button now in this case this
page is merely getting refreshed it's
not we are not coming here because the
button has been pressed so this state is
only going to get set once we actually
press the button
so now if I go back all the way to my
app component and again we type in
chicken press search just go to any
recipe let's just try that one
and now if I open up my console we can
see we have an object and that we do
have a state object and inside of it we
have the title which is called
whatever it was called chicken param
India and I don't know what it is but
anyway the good news is that we can use
this state to display the data on to
this recipe application okay so let's
just do that now so back in this recipe
dodge as well there is a reason why I
set this up as a class-based component
and the reason is that we're gonna make
use of State inside of this component
okay so first of all let's just go ahead
and declare our state and the state's
gonna be called active recipe and for
now let's just set it to an empty array
okay well next what's next well we're
gonna make use of a react built-in
method or in other words called a
lifecycle hook called component did
mount this method is going to get fired
as soon as this component gets loaded or
gets mounted onto the web browser so
anything that happens inside of it is
gonna happen
as soon as this component loads on the
screen okay and we're actually gonna do
something pretty similar to what we did
in apologia so for the most part what
I'm gonna do is I'm just going to go
ahead and copy everything that's inside
of this good recipe method and we're
just gonna change a few things for now
let's just paste them and we also need
our API key okay copy this go back to
the recipe component and paste it right
there so what exactly are we going to
change
well there is no recipe name in this
component because obviously there is no
form so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go ahead and delete this and I'm gonna
instead type in title because the title
is what we're gonna grab in order to
display the data so title is what what
do we equate to we have an object there
right so this dot props and then its
location so this dot props on and then
location dot state and then the property
is called recipe and remember we are
getting this because back in recipes
does yes while we set up the state and
then state the recipe okay so this
location actually is this dot crops
location and then its state and then its
recipe excellent so now what we need to
do is we need to replace this recipe
name with this title right there because
this recipe name constant does not exist
anymore and we can also get rid of this
count okay so we can get rid of that and
I'm just gonna copy this and I'm gonna
paste it right there and we don't need
this edad prevent default because there
is no form right there so we can just
get go ahead and get rid of that as well
alright so next up let's just change the
names of these two constants because
they already exist inside of this
applied J's file and it's not gonna make
a difference but it's best not to have
any duplicates so I'm gonna change this
to rec or request and I'm gonna change
that to res or results or response
whatever you want to call it and let's
just get rid of these two statements
right there and for now let's just
console
this res right there all right so press
save go back to the web browser and it
says that API call is not defined and
line number 13 so let's take a look at
what's going wrong all right of course
we need to change this to rec okay
say go back to the web browser and we
are on the recipe components and there
we go we do have a count showing up but
it's actually 18 recipes it's giving us
and the reason for this is because the
recipe that we clicked on maybe has more
than one name so you know is cashew
chicken pasta you can see this quite a
few of these so to fix that the the most
relevant recipe is gonna be the topmost
recipe in the array in this case the
index is zero so instead of grabbing
everything that's inside of this recipes
right what we can do is we can say rat
sir remember rez is this whole objects
arrest recipes and then we just need to
grab the first element in the array so
in this case we're gonna grab the
element with the index of zero okay
press save go back to the web browser
and now we can see that we're only
getting the recipe with this ID that we
searched for which is four six double
lines eggs and this is the title and
these are all the images and you know
the publisher that we're gonna use to
display the data okay brilliant so
what's next so now we're gonna make use
of this active recipe state right there
to actually display the data unsee our
actual screen okay so to do that let's
just type let's just get rid of this
console.log right there for now and
instead just type in this top set state
and then it's gonna take an object and
then we're gonna assign the active
recipe state the exact same thing that
we will that we were console logging
earlier so that was res that recipe and
then the first index inside of it okay
press save and now instead of console
logging the res object let's just
console.log the actual state this duck
state dot active recipe press save
go back to the web browser and we should
still get back the same thing
let's beyond so let's take a look why so
it says actually it should be recipes
okay
now this should work let's go back to
the web browser and yes we already did
getting back the same thing okay so now
how do we use this piece of state to
actually display the data onto our
actual you know this whole screen right
there well let's just add a bit of
structure inside of this render method
so I'm actually gonna get rid of this
whole thing and you're just gonna have
to watch me type a bunch of you know
markup using they're using the classes
and some of the bootstrap classes so the
first one we're gonna start off with is
called container and this is going to
act as the wrapper div and then inside
of container what we're gonna do is I
think the next class that comes is a
because we we don't need to add a row
because in this case we aren't really
throwing in any columns all we need is
just a big image and then underneath
that just the title and the publisher
and that's it so we don't really need to
add any rows or anything so what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna throw in a
custom class that vibe return and this
is called active - recipe okay let's
crack open this and inside of it we're
gonna grab the image so remember we do
have access to all these properties just
like we did in a project file so in this
image tag I'm gonna give it a class of I
believe is active recipe underscore
underscore image and then the source is
gonna be hmm now see if we type in this
state the active recipe and then you
know grab all these values this is going
to get a bit messy I mean we gonna have
to do this for the title we're gonna
have to do this for for the publisher
for the website so an easy way to fix
this is to actually store that into a
constant so just above this return
statement
we can do is we can create a new
constant and we can call it recipe and
then we can set it to this dot state dot
effective recipe okay so now instead of
typing out this whole thing we can just
copy this and we can paste it right
there and now that's what we need to
type in order to grab the values of the
object okay so now recipe thought and
then it's image underscore URL and for
the outside let's just give it recipe
dot title excellent press save let's
take a look at what's going on in the
web browser and there we go we do have
the image showing up and this is
brilliant so that means everything is
working fine so let's move on ok so
right below this image tag I'm gonna
throw in a haste three title tag and I'm
gonna give it a class name of thing its
I'm just gonna have to go ahead and copy
this active recipe because this is the
prefix to every class name and then the
prefix is title okay and the title is
obviously going to be recipe doctor
title okay moving on let's add a H four
in there and I'm gonna give this a class
name of I think it's respected recipe
and then we're gonna also grab this
publisher because you know we're just
gonna show that who actually created
this recipe so we're gonna grab this
publisher property so I'm just gonna go
ahead and copy this whole thing and
paste it right there and I'm gonna
replace this title with I think it's
publisher yep okay and within there
let's just throw in actually let's just
break this into a multiple line because
we're also gonna throw in a span tag so
let's type in publisher and then open up
a span tag and then inside of it I'm
just gonna add a I'm just gonna grab the
property's recipe publisher okay
brilliant so what's next well just below
this
h4 tag let's throw in a paragraph tag
and give it a class name of I'm just
gonna go ahead and copy this active
recipe underscore underscore and this is
going to be the website of the publisher
so in this case we're gonna grab come on
where's the website so publisher
publishes new RL recipe ID title I think
it's this one right there
so sure oh yeah that's it Oh publisher
URL actually this one right there so
this is the property that we're gonna
grab in order to let users know that you
know this is the website of this recipe
creator so again we're gonna break this
down into multiple a new line and I'm
just going to type in the word website
right there adds in a colon and then
right there I'm gonna type in a span and
I'm gonna give that inside of it it's
gonna be an anchor tag because obviously
we need to redraw it we need to redirect
our users to their website so the H wrap
is going to be so why is it recipe
publisher publisher URL okay recipe
publisher and then underscore URL and
didn't there let's just type in the
exact same thing so I'm actually just
gonna go ahead and copy this and paste
it right there because we're actually
gonna display the website onto the
screen as well alright so the last thing
that we need in there is the actual
button that we are going to go ahead and
print now so button and this is going to
be responsible for taking us back to the
home page so let's just give it a class
name of and I'm just gonna go ahead and
copy this act your recipe thing paste it
right there and then it's cold but turn
okay and let's just type in go home
brilliant press save go back to the web
browser and we should have our desired
desired results yes we do okay so
now you may notice that before the page
loads this whole blank thing is showing
up right there and we don't want that so
what do we do to change that
well let's just make a check we can
check that if the because you know since
all these values are coming from the
stage so we can just make a simple check
that if this state has a length of 0
then we don't want to display anything
because if it's 0 that means that this
array is empty this active recipe state
is empty which means that nothing is
inside of it so as soon as it gets
filled we can actually display our data
okay so to do that I'm actually going to
cut out everything that's inside of this
active recipe tab and open up a
JavaScript expression and inside of it
I'm just gonna type so we're gonna make
use of the and operator so as you know
for the and operator both of the
conditions have to be true in order for
something to execute okay so we can say
that this that state dot active recipe
and then since it's an array we can grab
a length property and we can check that
if this is not equal to 0 so again if
anything is inside of this array the
length is gonna be greater than 0 so if
this dot state dot active recipes length
is not equal to 0 only then do we want
to render out everything that that's
inside of this tip that we just cut out
so there we go
we're making use of the and operator and
now we can just go ahead and paste our
dev right there
excellent so I'm just going to indent
some of the stuff in that's like but
actually this should be there and then
this should be there okay now if you go
back to the web browser we can see that
nothing shows up until the page actually
loads and then the state gets filled so
we need to actually make this go
homework button work as well so how do
we do that because you know we can't
really make use of the actual a tag
because that's gonna result into a full
page refresh so if you are guessing that
we're gonna make use of react router
then you are absolutely right so first
of all we need to grab a named export
from react router okay and that is gonna
be linked and remember we did we did use
this link right there in recipes as well
and that is exactly what we never do
inside this recipe components as well
okay so I'm just gonna go ahead and
break this button down into multiple
lines cut this out and open up a link
tag and paste it right there now the
only thing that we need to provide here
is the path name so remember we have two
parts we have the home path and then we
have the recipe path so currently in
this inside of the suspect components we
are indeed on the recipe path so right
there all we need to do is we need to
say that once this button has been
clicked take us back to the home page so
for the home page the path is forward
slash okay
so now if we go back to the web browser
and we can see that this has been
converted to a link and if I press this
we get taken to the home page and from
there on we can search for another
recipe so actually let's type something
different because we have used taken
quite a bit okay shrimp and then let's
just go to one of these new recipe and
then yeah it's working just fine from
there on we can go back to our home page
using this go home button okay so our
application is pretty much done for the
most part the only thing that's left now
is you know when they go back to the
home page
our results are gone so we want you know
we we want to keep our results you know
when they go back to the home page we
don't really want to search through the
you know the index again and grab
everything we want to we want we want
our easel
to be there just the way they were
before we navigated away from this page
so let's take care of that inside of our
approaches file okay so I'm just gonna
close everything else because I don't
think we need anything else anymore now
inside of this Abdo JS file we're gonna
make use of a couple new react lifecycle
hooks and those who are component did
update and component did mount actually
we've used component did not already so
the only new one is component did update
so component did update works something
like this we don't really need these two
arguments because these are for
something a little more advanced but
essentially the way this works is
whatever happens inside of this method
is going to happen as soon as the
component has updated and then does the
component using the update
well when the state changes okay so as
soon as the state updates the component
is going to update as well so as soon as
that happens what we're gonna do is
we're gonna create a constant alright
and we're gonna call it recipes and then
we're just gonna make use of the local
storage to store our data so what we're
gonna do is first of all we're gonna
convert this into you know our or a
recipe state into the JSON format
because local storage only takes strings
it doesn't take any objects it doesn't
take any erase it it'll takes any
numbers nothing it just takes string it
just takes the string so as JSON
basically is just a one big string so to
convert this we're gonna say json
stringify
and then what what do we need to string
if i well we need to string if I this
recipe state so json dot stringify and
then this dot state dot recipes okay so
once that's been done we need to
actually assign it to local storage so
to do that we can just say in local
storage and then you set that item in
local storage you use the property
called set item
and it takes a couple of arguments the
first one is the name of the item which
is going to store this recipe array
right there
so we need to provide that in to in a
string so I'm just gonna call it recipes
and the second argument is the actual
thing that you want to store and in this
case we want to store our recipes a
recipe state so this is what we're gonna
type in right there okay so now if we go
back to our web browser open up the
state and let's just search for chicken
because right now it hasn't been updated
but it's going to get updated as soon as
you press search because that's when the
state updates so now from there let's
just look for local storage because I
kind of forgot where it lives
performance application local storage
and there we go we can see that
everything that we lives for is inside
of this recipes object so right there if
we type in local storage don't get item
and then what did we set the item to is
recipes right so get item is an other
method on local storage which we can use
to grab the items that we set so in this
case we set the recipes item right there
so we can say local storage don't get
item and then if you press it press
Enter we can see that we are getting
everything in form of a string so you
can see this is a quotation mark and it
ends right there at the end and this is
why it's a very ugly format because this
is not Jason this is just a bondic
string all right so what's next well
once we have actually set this to local
storage now using another life cycle
hook called component did mount we're
just going to that's not it now in this
method we're just going to fetch
everything that's inside of our local
storage so to do that we first need to
grab of a stored item which in this case
is recipe so I'm just gonna create in
your constant and I'm gonna call it JSON
okay and I'm gonna set it to local
storage thoughts and then in order to
get tonight's and we use the get atom
property and then we're gonna grab the
recipes assume that we just set okay so
now we first need to convert it to the
actual JSON format because currently
it's in the string format because we
can't display any strings or any the
type on to the web browser so it has to
be in JSON okay so we can say great we
can create a new content called recipes
and then we can say JSON and then to
parse a string we say json dot parse and
then we can type we can pass in this
JSON constraint right there okay
excellent
so now all we need to do is we just need
to set this recipes to this recipe
straight right there okay so this set
State and then an object and then
recipes and then this constant right
there okay and now one need bit of
syntax in es6 is that if the name of the
of the property and the key if these two
names are the same then you can just
make it something like this okay if it
was something like recipe then we would
actually have to type it this way but in
es6 if the names of the keys and the
values are the same then you can just do
something like this okay now if you
press save go back to the web browser we
can see that we are indeed going through
a full page refresh but nothing is
changing we can see that we is still
getting the results and let's just look
for something else let's look for garlic
press search and let's just you let's
just view one of these recipes let's
just mute this one and we are indeed
getting it back now if you go back to
the home page we can see that we still
have the recipe that we searched for
okay well this is it for this video and
I really hope you learned something from
it thank you very much for watching and
I will see you next time goodbye